I'm wondering when okay you obviously
are part in my opinion of the best super
group in rap history West Side
connection yeah
I think bow down is
top five
rap album in West Coast history it's up
there man for sure gangster killing a
dope dealers [__] you know right one
of my favorite songs ever right do you
give Mount Westmore a listen when they
drop their super album
like do you check it out as a fan like
just to see like oh you know we kind of
did our super group like let me see what
these guys are doing
uh not really yeah not really I mean uh
I've I've heard bits and pieces of it
you know what I'm saying but
not not really yeah West Side connection
was a movement a movement yeah it was a
little different a movement yeah and
it's crazy too because like if you think
about like from like bow down to
terrorist threats how many years was
that was that like nine or ten years
difference seven years of fight
something like something like that yeah
yes or something like yeah yeah and it
felt like y'all kind of like picked up
right where y'all left off with those
like right
bow down would you put that up there
with any one of your solo albums in
terms of just bodies of work oh yeah oh
yeah that's a complete body of work yeah
and it was sincere what were like those
Studio sessions like when you guys do
like gangsters Make the World Go Round
like tell me about that record like that
studio session uh
you know it was like uh any other West
Side connect studio session I mean it
was always friendly competition yeah you
know your verse had to be high
you know period just everything it was
friendly competition It was friendly
competition for sure you know about your
your verse your verse had to be hot you
know and if your [__] wasn't hot
somebody might say oh man [__] you might
want to run that back you might want to
go back and write that [__] over or
something did you have to say that to
cube ever I mean you know every every
everybody
if if you've been honest with somebody
and you done did
as many records as we have together
everybody respect everybody's opinion
yeah you know what I'm saying it could
be a little homie in the room that that
might say to me
you sure you want to say it like you
know what I'm saying and and and and if
and if you open-minded dude and you know
everybody got your best interest
you at least gonna gonna hear what he
got to say you know what I'm saying you
you might not always go back and change
it but you you you if you're trying to
make Classics you at least got an open
mind you know you least
open to listen